welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Christopher you jury the Henry J
Heinz the second professor of economics
at Yale University professor you jury is
a development economist whose research
focuses on twirl economic activity in
sub-saharan Africa he has conducted
extensive field research in West Africa
on technological change in agriculture
the use of financial markets asset
accumulation and gift exchange to cope
with risk gender relations and the
structure of household economics
property rights and a variety of other
aspects of rural economic organization
today we'll talk with Professor u jury
about land rights and agricultural
investment in Ghana
welcome professor you jury thanks for
inviting me in your paper the profits of
power you examine the relationship
between land and politics in Ghana give
us an overview ok so this this paper is
part of a larger research program to try
to understand the relationships between
social relations political structure and
institutions and economic activity in in
in Africa generally in West Africa in
particular most of my work is in Ghana
because it helps to understand the
institutional context the political
context to reveal these underlying
economic behaviors so in this paper we
do two things source it's a co-authored
paper with Marcus goldstein at the World
Bank it's full credit for participating
in this and in this paper we do two
basic things first we show that there's
a strong relationship between people's
political and social position within
local hierarchies of power within
villages in rural areas in Ghana and the
security with which they control their
land people who are remote from centres
of power locally
are much more likely to lose control
over their land over the next year or
two than people who are more central to
networks of power and second we show
that those people who don't have secure
rights to land are much less able to
make investments in the land as a
consequence they achieve much lower
output much lower profits and in yeah
that's so so they they achieve much
little profits much lower output and as
a consequence they have much lower
incomes and how did you come to write
the paper what was your inspiration okay
so in West Africa in Africa generally
actually people tend to farm plots by
themselves so rather than a family farm
like you might have in the Midwest of
the United States instead if you go to a
plot of land that'll be an individual
plot so a man will be farming this part
of his wife will be farming a plot over
there their son will be farming a
different plot so agricultural
productions organized individually and
people have control over the income from
their plots and I've shown and others
have shown and work around Africa that
there's a very strong gender
differential that that husbands and
wives even if they're married to each
other will achieve very different yields
very different profits and very
different incomes from their
agricultural activities with men
achieving much higher profits than their
wives and so this is a mystery we don't
quite understand what's going on with
that and in some work I was doing in
southern Ghana I noticed this pattern
reappearing that men were cheating much
higher yields than their wives we're
achieving and we collected enough data
in this case to start to unravel the
mystery of why there was this this
difference and it was clear that it was
related to investments people were
making in their land that women were
making much lower investments than their
husbands were in the investment that
matters in most of the forest areas of
the world is following that you farm
your land for a year or two and then you
leave it alone for a few years and
during that time it regenerates its
fertility and the
the weed load is diminished by
competition and as a consequence when
you farm it again it's much more
productive and we noticed that woman
were leaving their land fallow for very
short periods of time relative to their
husbands so so this was actually really
fun we I was spending time in these
villages and in informal conversations
with men and women and and also more
formal focus groups I was able to
confront them with data from their land
I was able to sit down with the man and
say look here's your wives plots you
jerk your plots you're getting much
higher output than your wives why why is
this and of course the men just say it's
because we're good farmers and our wives
aren't but sitting down with the woman
and talking with women about why this
was we could talk about specific plots
we could talk about that land behind
your house why'd you you cultivated it
last year and you had only left it
fallow for a matter of months and
naturally you got very low yield why why
would you do this when your husband
leaves his land fallow for years and he
gets much higher yields and they of
course knew of this pattern they knew
they were doing this and they knew as
well the link between investment and
productivity they knew they were getting
low yields as a consequence of leaving
their land fallow but one woman said to
me and this is this was really quite
vivid I I can't leave it fallow if I
leave it fallow it's not my land its
land that I get from my husband's family
through a process I could describe to
you but through it through a convoluted
political process she got the right to
cultivate this land if she didn't
cultivate it that would indicate to the
people who gave her the land that she
didn't really need it and as a
consequence they would take it away so
she had to keep cultivating it so it
became clear that there was a link
between her rights to land and the way
she got land and her investment
decisions and then in turn her output
and as a consequence her income and so
her husband had much more income than
she did as a consequence of his ability
to invest in his land because he had
more secure rights to the land so that's
what started us off on right
okay and why is it important to look at
this relationship between land and
politics
well there's first of all it's very
clear that there's big gender
differences in welfare in in West Africa
and in in parts of East Africa as well
where the women are getting much less
income than their husbands are and
they're getting this much less income
fundamentally because they're much less
productive on in agriculture which is
their main activity and so trying to
understand why there's this productivity
difference is central to understanding
this gendered division of income that's
so that's so unequal in much of Africa
so that's that's that's one reason why
it's important to look at this
the second reason it's important to look
at this is that our work shows that this
connection between local politics and
people's ability to make investments and
in their land and hence to generate
income and so this this nexus between
politics and production turns out to be
much more important than than we might
have thought now I wouldn't want anyone
to take our paper and say that the same
thing occurs in other places have even
gone certainly in other places of Africa
the way this connection between politics
land rights investment works itself out
in southern Ghana
is a consequence of this specific way
political power is organized the
specific way that land rights are
visualized and enforced and the specific
agricultural system so that that
specific connection wouldn't necessarily
be general but the the general lesson is
that in understanding patterns of
investment you have to understand
people's security of property rights
that seems to be a general result from
this and that property and political
power are linked in important ways in
Africa in ways that we still have to
explore in southern Ghana is fairly
clear of what that link is but in other
parts of West Africa there's there
somewhere but we don't really quite
understand those power dynamics and how
it leads to
property rights so that's that's why I
think okay it's curious to me and
listening to you say that a man and a
woman are married okay a man can let his
land go fallow for years but his wife
who he lives with seems penalized I'm
wondering why the husband and wife do
not work together on the land and why
the husband wouldn't be upset if someone
took his wife's land away can you speak
to that well be upset land away but
never so so there was there a bunch of
questions in there yeah there's one deep
question which we really don't
understand that well which is why
productive enterprises in Africa all
over Africa are much more individualized
than they are say in the US where
households tend to work together more
the the same question could be asked in
Reverse of course while I talked about
this in Africa people asked well why
would you do things jointly rather than
separately people have that people have
comparative advantage some people are
better at certain things than other
things and so that's why we tend to
specialize and that's why Africans tend
to specialize in separate activities
another reason why they tend to
specialize in separate activities is
they're very small returns to scale and
so everybody who's a farmer in Africa is
farming multiple plots and so these are
divisional enterprises the visible
enterprises so because we've got five or
six different plots scattered around the
village it makes a bit of sense that one
person will be responsible for this plot
another responsible for another plot
then turning but but then the question
becomes how do you get those plots and
that's how it links into the local
politics the man is going to be upset if
his wife loses his land but he doesn't
have the ability to protect her because
she has to get that land sometimes with
his help but through the village
allocation mechanism that gives people
land and so as much as he might protest
she might still lose her land and he's a
better able to protect his land we
the norms of land allocation in these
villages which give him more secure
rights over those because he is a man
it's not so much because he's a land
it's interesting it's more because
because he's a man he is much more
likely to be closely connected to
village leaders who are of course all
men these power differences aren't
gendered in themselves they're
correlated with gender but we can have
exceptions where we have powerful women
who have secure land rights and
unpowered men who don't have let's talk
about your methodology how did you do
the research yeah so I do use all sorts
of different methods and the method that
is appropriate depends upon the question
here's in in this study
my co-author Marcus Goldstein I've spent
a total of two years living in Ghana
running a relatively small very
intensive survey of a few hundred
households several hundred people where
we would visit them and our research
assistants would visit everybody in our
sample every four to six weeks to get
very detailed information on what was
going on in their economic lives for
this paper what mattered was very
detailed information on what they were
doing on their lands every activity that
took place on their land and in depth
interviews about how they got their
lands and what they were doing with
their land so the foundation of the work
was a survey with data collection
complemented by a lot of informal
interviews with Marcus and I spending a
lot of time in these villages talking
with people about what's up we started
this work thinking that it was going to
be about the relations between husbands
and wives that it was all about
relations within the household and it
certainly has something to do with that
but over time it emerged that it was
much more about each individual's
connections with a larger social
structure and we had to map that out
over time so it was a it's an iterative
process we start with an idea about
what's going on turns out you're wrong
but but from that idea you generated and
data to enable to enable you to figure
out that you're wrong and in what
direction you can modify the data
collection to to recover from your
errors now given these results where we
find the strong connection between
political power land rights investment
productivity and income it called out
for for further works so with colleagues
at the economic growth center here at
Yale and colleagues at the University of
Ghana where we have a long-term research
relationship we're now doing a 15 to 20
year study across the entire country
looking at this question and many other
questions over over over time within
Ghana so that we can see how this
evolves as the process of development
takes place very good and in doing the
research did you have any difficulty or
was there anything that was particularly
surprising well we were we were pretty
wrong as we started in our idea about
what was going to be the the finding
we've we thought that this gender
difference was going to be all about
power relations within the household and
it was only through conversations with
mostly the woman that led us to start
investigating more carefully the local
village political economy which led us
then to collect an entirely different
set of data rich data on all the social
network connections between people
within the village so we could see who
was connected to whom and and to try to
measure the political power of of people
so we did a lot of interviews about who
the Chiefs are who the who the local
political activists were and trying to
understand in which political party
people were and who was in power and who
was not so that so so so being wrong in
the first place which we found out
mostly through statistical analysis then
led us to revise what we were doing and
collect more data that enabled us to
uncover this more surprising result this
is
systematic pattern whenever I've done
field research like this over over the
last decade or two you can have a pretty
good idea from the literature that
exists beforehand but because most of
the literature on which which talks
about social interactions within
villages in West Africa is qualitative
it it tells you what sort of relations
exist but it doesn't give you very much
power to understand the relative
importance of different mechanisms so of
course there's disputes within the
household and power relations within the
household matter but in the realm of
life of property rights of land it turns
out that those were second order
importance compared to power relations
within the village more generally and so
I find over and over again that I'm a
little bit off when I start my research
project so it's important to build in
enough time for recovery as you find out
that you're wrong and people tell you
that you're wrong and so ok so the work
you know that you have done in this
paper you are going to kind of
extrapolate it out to you're working on
another project when do you you know
what do you think that will hold I mean
what do you think that will show well
what's so against starting with a
certain premise and then having it be
wrong what do you think is going to
happen yeah so we'll see what's what's
what's really exciting about extending
it to a larger canvas to the country as
a whole rather than four villages in
southern Ghana when you expand to the
country as a whole we're sure to see
different things in different places and
so it calls out from much more
collaboration and so the this larger
program that we're doing with the
University of Ghana now which will take
place of a scan of multiple years rather
than two or three years from talking 10
15 20 years of research this is this
this just requires collaboration and so
we have a bunch of students PhD students
from Yale from the
gaana whole team of really wonderful
research assistants based at the
University of Ghana who are living in
these villages and collecting this data
over the long term that what I think
will generate different results in
different parts of the country will find
that in the north of the country which
is much poorer and has a very different
agricultural system and the land right
system is entirely different I'm a
hundred percent confident well ok 95
percent confident that we won't find a
similar mechanism at at play instead
there'll be something different we still
find up there
gender differences there's a big
difference between the productivity of
men's and women's plots but I suspect
there's something different going on it
may have to do with the control of
animals rather than the control of land
animals are more important in that part
of the country and in the cocoa belt of
Ghana which is the main export crop of
Ghana there there seems to be almost
systematic exclusion of women from the
production of this main export crop and
we don't quite understand what's going
on there and so there's a sociologist
working with us who from the University
of Ghana may be able to help us figure
out what's going on well thank you so
much for being here with us today and
sharing some of your work great it was
really fun for more information about
professor ug and his work please visit
our website at Yale edu backslash
Macmillan report be sure to join us
again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
you